hey it's me again we're going to talk
about evaluation again here's another
example we're going to take a look at
this 35 year old female just like you
would a mechanic would look at an engine
dysfunctioning or a engineer would look
at a problem only in medicine do they
separate everything out and they're over
specialized they treat each thing
separately they treat it they don't take
all the data they don't look at the body
as a whole
you don't understand what symptoms mean
and the bunny they're just like
suppressed so medicine has become the
management of symptoms so we're gonna
just dissect the her data number one she
has daily headaches high pulse rate high
system pressure that's the top number of
the blood pressure is high rash can't
tolerate sun dry skin fatigue and then
we put all the symptoms in this
digestion bucket here irritable bowel
bloating needs magnesium to eliminate
burping pain on the left side of her
shoulder back and neck nausea floating
stool gallbladder removed then we have
libido is down
she took Astrid in ER she's taking
estrogen for fertility and Hashimoto's
kale makes her hair fall out
it's thyroid adrenal red cheeks puffy
eyes sleep allergies nervous all right
so now let's just look at this thing
the thing that I had jumps out to me is
the most problems are in this digestive
thing now bloating burping that's
gallbladder symptoms but she had a
gallbladder removed so it's still a
deficiency of bio so we know we have a
deficiency of bile okay but typically
that problem is going to cause pain on
the right side of the shoulder and neck
not the left so she has left sided
shoulder and come wraps right around the
back and that would mean that's pancreas
so that's a pancreatic problem so let's
write this down
pancreatic insufficiency that's the kind
of that would create these symptoms
because the pancreas if it swells up or
if it works too hard it will irritate
the tissue right around the pancreas
which there's a is a little nerve called
the phrenic nerve it's on both sides
then the left side it goes right up to
your right shoulder right up through
here so the pancreas now let's take a
look at pancreatic insufficiency what
does that mean the pancreas makes
enzymes so it also regulates insulin but
if it's not making all the enzymes which
makes sense because if she has a
gallbladder problem she's not going to
actually have a really really healthy
pancreas they both work together in the
digestive tract so whatever she ate in
the past that destroyed that gallbladder
is probably also made the pancreas weak
as well and depleted the enzymes but the
symptoms for pancreatic insufficiency
are very similar to low bile very
similar so right here nausea that could
be the pancreas the flute the stool that
floats that could be a pancreatic
insufficiency because you're not able to
release enough lipase that's fat enzymes
so when bile comes in there breaks down
the fat lipase from the pancreas
dissolves that fat even further down to
a stage where you can digest it so this
could easily be pancreatic insufficiency
right here and so could not
so could pain on the left side and
irritable bowel because you're gonna
have a lot of inflammatory issues as
well if you don't have the enzymes so
that's one thing now let's just take a
look at let's see here rash that could
be another symptom can't tolerate some
well this is really a low vitamin K
deficiency because CSUN gives you a lot
of vitamin D but if you don't have
vitamin K that can create a symptom of
vitamin D toxicity okay which is like
like it's like Sun is toxic to you but
because she doesn't have a gallbladder
we know that she doesn't have enough of
the bile to absorb some of these fats
and vitamins so she's getting you know
she might just basically get all the Sun
on the skin and go in but she's not
getting all the other vitamins to
balance it out so this can relate to
this vile thing right here dry skin well
that just indicates that she's not
absorbing some of the oils and the fats
in the skin because she doesn't have the
bile so that's interesting and then we
write here Hashimoto's let's try to
figure that out
Hashimoto's is an autoimmune and
autoimmune there is some data on enzyme
deficiencies and autoimmune but I don't
know if that relates but I do know that
if the adrenal is to stress they can get
autoimmune of pretty much any organ but
I would like to before I evaluate this
I'd like to get a history of when it
started what happened just before it was
there a stress event or reserve
something was it that they took the
gallbladder out so I can't really know
that kale makes her hair fall well
that's too much kale and some people can
block it can block iodine and that can
affect especially as she already has a
thyroid issue she probably needs to be
taking iodine but look at this she's
taking estrogen decreased libido this is
estrogen dominance see the thyroid it's
very rare to have a primary thyroid the
thyroid is usually influenced by three
things one a lack of bile because t4 is
converted to t3 through the liver that
would make a lot of sense or it can come
from high estrogen associate we have two
things that can cause that or it could
be the adrenal as well so it could be
any one of those things so what I would
do with this case is that would just
take one thing I would support the
pancreas first then the bile and then
see how many of these things clear up
because for example high pulse rate
that's the heart working harder be
probably because she doesn't have the
fat side vitamins to transport the
minerals and calcium around and see if
that doesn't just clear these things out
right here so that's the first thing I
would try and then I would support the
adrenals and then I might you know
recommend that she doesn't alternative
for this estrogen thing because that
there's too many side effects with
that's what estrogen so I would just
take the most likely thing first address
that and then the next one boom boom
boom to see what's going to really clear
out most of these issues but it looks to
me that if her digestion is better
should be converting more thyroid
hormones should be able to detoxify
estrogen better from her body and she'll
be able to absorb more nutrients she's
gonna have to take some bile extract for
the rest of her life because she doesn't
have a gallbladder purified bile salts
but to support the pancreas and get rid
of all these things that would probably
give her a huge relief and allow her to
sleep take the stress off the adrenals
so that's where I would start first all
right so that's just kind of a I'm just
talking out loud but that's how I would
take a look at this case